hi I'm Joe Russo and I'm Anthony Russo
and we directed Avengers endgame there
was an idea to bring together a group of
remarkable people what was your favorite
moment to film out of all four movies
you made for Marvel Studios the elevator
sequence from Captain America because
the first thing that we ever shot for a
Marvel film does anyone want to get out
what was the biggest I open for you both
when using an IMAX camera for the first
time when Captain America Civil War one
of the great revelations using an IMAX
camera was we have many characters of
different sizes sometimes that can be
challenging to frame with an IMAX camera
though you have a lot more vertical
frame space so you can hold like very
large characters in the same frame as
smaller characters I just finally know
what I have to do what was your reaction
to the fan theories did any of them
surprise you I like this one we love fan
theories we love how creative people are
about where these stories can go where
the characters can tell the most
surprising and favorite was famous
advice for going from the small screen
to the biggest screen there is an IMAX
you know it's just really focusing on
telling stories and caring about stories
when you're working movies of this scale
IMAX is the best format because this
pure scale these films can only be
captured on the biggest screen
[Music]
you
you